this topic was originally intended to be
one video but to keep it a reasonable
length I'll be splitting it into two
parts part two will be uploaded this
coming Tuesday
Close Encounters of the Third Kind
contact arrival the idea of humanity's
first communication with
extraterrestrial life has been an
exciting topic for decades countless
books movies TV shows in every other
form of media have long speculated what
first contact would look like would they
be little green men giant tentacled
monsters would we even be able to
communicate what if they're not friendly
as popular a topic as it is for science
fiction how prepared are we for first
contact in real life since the 1970s
there have been a handful of projects
dedicated to the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence with
varying degrees of funding one of the
earliest major endeavors was known as
project Cyclops which was initiated by
NASA to determine the best way to search
for signals from extraterrestrial
sources however the project
recommendations were disregarded in
favor of the less expensive messaging to
extraterrestrial intelligence which
simply broadcast messages that
intelligent life could intercept more
recently
funding for SETI programs has been
massively reduced and has had to rely on
private donations to continue the search
but enough about the search for life
what we're concerned about in this video
is how prepared we are is there any
protocol in place for the event of first
contact perhaps surprisingly yes there
is the main official document goes by
the catchy name the Declaration of
Principles for activities following the
detection of extraterrestrial
intelligence originally drafted by the
SETI permanent Committee of the
International Academy of astronautics
the IAA the Declaration of Principles
has since been approved and endorsed by
most researchers involved in the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence the
Declaration is broken up into eight
provisions one any detection of
extraterrestrial signals should be
verified as coming from an intelligence
source before being announced to any
individual upon discovering a signal
should communicate with other
signatories of the declaration before
making a public announcement and should
also inform their national authorities
three once a signal has been determined
to be legitimate
the astronomical community should be
informed as well as the
secretary-general of the United Nations
and various other global scientific
Union
for following confirmation of
intelligent extraterrestrial origin
the discovery should be made public the
individual or group responsible for the
discovery has the right to make the
first public announcement 5 all data
relevant to the discovery should be
published to the international
scientific community and stored in
accessible form as permanently as
possible 6 if the evidence for
extraterrestrial intelligence takes the
form of electromagnetic signals the
secretary-general of the International
Telecommunications Union should be
contacted and may request to minimize
the terrestrial use of the
electromagnetic frequency bands in which
the signal was detected 7 no one should
respond to an observed extraterrestrial
intelligence doing so requires
international agreement under separate
procedures and finally number 8 the SETI
permanent Committee of the IAA and
Commission 51 of the International
Astronomical Union should continually
review procedures regarding detection of
extraterrestrial intelligence
additionally another agreement called
the proposed agreement on the sending of
communications to extraterrestrial
intelligence was drafted to supplement
the declaration it intended to form an
International Commission open to any and
all interested nations which would be
involved in the process of deciding how
to respond to messages from intelligent
life
this document promised to determine the
contents of their response with respect
to the principles of justice respect for
cultural diversity honesty and respect
for property and territory it also
forbids the response of any one nation
without the consent of the rest of the
committee and suggest that if the signal
were believed to be hostile the decision
of how to respond should fall to the
United Nations Security Council well
that sounds pretty good right maybe
unfortunately these documents hold no
official power they're more of
guidelines than actual rules and many
scientists expect they'd be ignored in
the event of real first contact contact
over long distance is one thing but what
if aliens were to physically land on
earth before we look at the possible
scenarios we have to consider historical
parallels take for example the Columbian
Exchange starting with Christopher
Columbus landing in North America in
1492 the Columbian Exchange refers to
the widespread transfer of plant animals
culture human populations technology and
ideas between the old world and the
Americas although there were many
positive aspects of this mingling of
populations the main effect was
disastrous for the natives diseases to
which the indigenous peoples have never
been
ravage their population causing a huge
decline in numbers many historians and
scientists speculates that the arrival
of extraterrestrials would have similar
effect on the native populations of
Earth however it is entirely possible
that the extra-terrestrial pathogens
would have no effect on earth as they
may only be suited to small and
exclusive set of environments not found
on our planet it's impossible to tell
so what provisions do we have in place
for the event of alien craft landing on
earth officially nothing no documents no
procedures nothing at the government
level that the public is aware of
according to Seth szostak a leader at
the SETI Institute in California he's
not aware of any government programs
covert or otherwise that are prepared
for physical extraterrestrial arrival
szostak cites an event from 1997 that he
believes should have triggered a
response from any such government
organization he says in 1997 we got a
signal that looks pretty promising for
most of the day we thought it was
possibly the real deal I kept waiting
for the men in black to show up they
didn't I kept waiting for the Pentagon
to call I kept waiting for the White
House to call they didn't call why is
that an event so historically
significant with as much potential for
global disaster certainly merits an
official plan right well it's hard to
form a gameplan when you don't know how
the game is played any civilization
capable of interstellar travel would be
at least hundreds of years more advanced
than humanity so it would be very
difficult to imagine what their arrival
might entail szostak compared it to
Neanderthals having a plan in case the
US Air Force showed up he has a point
having a plan might not matter at all
what could we possibly say to a far more
advanced civilization that they don't
already know and of course a knee-jerk
military response would probably end
very badly for us so with that in mind
what can we do to prepare make sure to
stay tuned for the next video where
we'll look at the potential effects
extraterrestrial civilizations could
have on earth if you enjoyed the music
in this video it's by some good friends
of mine in a band called the solid ocean
they're currently running a GoFundMe
campaign to raise enough money to get
their music recorded professionally in
LA if you have a moment and would like
to check them out I put a link in the
description to their GoFundMe page one
dollar or just a like on one of those
social media pages can make a big
difference
check out the links in the description
if you'd like to learn more about the
search for extraterrestrial life and
cultural exchange if you enjoyed this
video please take a moment to subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date with
the latest content feel free to leave a
like or a dislike as you please and
leave a comment down below with what you
think humanity should do to prepare for
first contact you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or watch them all
by clicking here thanks for watching
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]